toni morrison petites filles d'anciens
esclaves se rappelle que son grand-père
se vantait de lire la bible
alors que la lecture était interdite aux
noirs et aux illégaux
elise light oui comment cela m'a fait
comprendre dit elle le pouvoir des mots
elle fait de brillantes études en
littérature puis devient éditrice à la
reine d'hamra hausse à new york et la
première afro-américaine à enseigner à
l'université princeton deux institutions
ou les femmes noires de surcroît sont
très rares enfin à mumbai
elle encourage la publication
d'écrivains noir et commence à écrire
son premier roman de blood ties raconte
le désir d'une jeune fille noire d'avoir
des yeux bleus on continue d'inventer de
beaux personnages afro-américains ancrés
dans leur histoire et pour la première
fois dans la littérature américaine
le quotidien des noirs leurs joies et
leurs peines ne sont pas définies en
opposition ou blanc quasi absent de ses
romans tout va si on accepte volontiers
l'étiquette d'écrivain noir avec un
bémol
pendant quarante ans on lui a posé sans
cesse la même question pourquoi n'écrit
tels que sur les noirs fateh le jour
écrire autre chose que des histoires
raciale bastonnade paraissent elles
répondent et ont demandé à aimer zola
d'arrêter d'écrire sur les blancs
reviews n'a pas de réseau à l'ied à nos
mini hand and without the rileys avec
beloved consacré meilleur roman du
dernier quart de siècle elle obtient le
prix nobel de littérature
une autre première pour moi tu es revenu
morrison c'est une inspiration à écouter
c'est la première femme noire qui a
gagné quand même un prix assez
prestigieux en littérature donc le
message que sa lancée que c'est possible
continuer lâche pas écrit fait valoir à
voir gabriela quintero a ouvert cette
librairie à montréal nord qui est aussi
un lieu de rencontres et de lectures la
langue de l'oppression ne se contente
pas de représenter la violence elle est
la violence
la femme de 30 ans trouvé qu'il était
difficile de trouver au québec des
livres écrits par des auteurs de
couleurs comme toni morrison moi je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
est capable de nous transmettre de
grandes émotions tout simplement par la
lecture et nous lance des images quand
même assez très fortes qui nous
remettant en question qui nous font à
observer et critiqué le monde qui nous
entoure
oprah winfrey qui a fait connaître
l'oeuvre de son ami au grand public lui
a rendu hommage sur twitter elle a
utilisé le pouvoir des mots écrits tels
pour réveiller nos consciences
remuer nos blessures les plus profondes
et nous les faire comprendre que son
héritage survivre longtemps ici sophie
langlois radio canada montréal